you're milking it for all it's worth i
always am
let's serve up some news sunny side up
the new york times did a deep dive on
first pets throughout white house
history lincoln himself had dogs cats
and a pair of goat brothers what and a
turkey oh because you just throw the
turkey in
[Laughter]
albie jay was smitten with his little
mutt yuki who sat on his lap when he
signed bills i love that i know me too
good luck good omen and in fact 31 out
of 46 presidents had dogs but that's
just the tip of the pet iceberg
taft had a cow named pauline and she
grazed the south lawn and provided fresh
milk and butter this is utterly
fascinating
[Laughter]
no not with the otters i can't help it
it's where my mind goes you're milking
it for all it's worth i always am
this one i really liked fun fact
coolidge had a raccoon named rebecca who
was meant to be thanksgiving dinner but
became bffs with the first lady just in
time by the way raccoon
okay my turn next we're going to talk
about the latest dating term on the
block why am i reading this like that
roaches
like literally chris jenner character
style reports um roaching refers to when
the person you're dating is sleeping
with a ton of other people and not
telling you about it that's also called
being a horrible person yeah
there's a really simple thing you can
say if you know of even just one person
he's hooking up with other than you get
out the raid spray it ross
drew
have you ever been roached oh well i
mean i just assume here's the deal i i
think unless you're exclusive you're not
exclusive you know so you should just
assume uh you're getting roached and
ironically it doesn't bug me i think pun
intended yes totally intended
new york city is still buzzing after
last week's met gala
it was fashion week of course and um the
thing we didn't know we needed larry
david turned out to be the star of
fashion week um when he showed up to the
stad spring show and did this
okay
z way
what is it that loud what what is it i
was actually at that show and what was
ironic is that there was a celebrity dog
next to me and a producer approached the
dog and said there's gonna be loud
noises
and i think that you know maybe other
guests at the show clearly could have
benefited from that warning
so
could the dog take it because they
really do have the sensitive hearing the
dog was also carrying so but ultimately
it was a gorgeous show so worth it
deadline reports that the man behind the
champ sylvester stallone has hit a new
hollywood milestone
sly stars in the suicide squad which hit
number one at the box office which means
stallone has now had a number one movie
in six consecutive decades wow wow
that's why he's the champ he's made 46
films with 20 number ones like rocky
rambo cliffhanger driven and the
expendables congrats to sly on an
amazing career that just keeps going
absolutely
i always love sylvester stallone because
my growing up my dad always called me
rocky really yeah i don't know why maybe
i reminded him of sylvester stallone in
a way you know what i'll put him on a
pedestal any day
you've got big questions for horror fans
can an indie horror movie be just as
scary as one with a huge budget the new
york post reports that a company called
finance buzz is gonna test this they're
hiring a horror heart rate analyst to
watch 13 scary movies across all budgets
while wearing heart rate monitors
i know i love this the movies range from
a paranormal activity which costs 15 000
to make it's a good one to a quiet place
too which cost 60 million
all right nate yes
thoughts i love horror movies
i'm all in i'm all in you guys love
horror movies
got a couple snaps up there yeah
i feel like uh fear is something we
don't tap into enough you know i love a
good jump out scare when you're walking
down the hallway i love a good haunted
house no
today in our little yellow book she's an
inspiration to all of us you have her on
your wall in your show it's oprah
i love that she said live your best life
how clever is that the turn of phrase
your makes it about you and not about
her
and now we have oprah daly which is like
lets you just know you can be on that
feeder and totally satisfied um and she
has a new digital series um on the
oprahdaily.com called the oprah daily
insiders roundtable
it's hosted by the one and only gail
king who's a friend of the show
and mine and with incredible guests like
glennon doyle um ashley c ford talking
about the big issues and we are thrilled
because we are teaming up with oprah
daily for an ongoing partnership oprah
daily editors will be sharing the latest
oprah daily scoops here all season long
and we're kicking it off today
[Applause]
[Music]